[Musique]
là qu'est ce que tu vois toi tout seul
oui mais tout va rien moi je suis
chocolat il ya quelqu'un qui tombait
sous le coup de la capot et qu'elle
continue à taper alors que la personne
est par terre c'est ça c'est ça bien que
nous moi mes sentiments
ils sont restés là j'en ai plus
j'en ai plus j'ai honte geo parce que
justement de m'apercevoir que les autres
ont toujours de la peine alors que moi
mais mettant mieux que je suis comme ça
parce que sinon si j'étais malade ça
fois que je reviens mesure même si ici
il est très sympathique
je viendrai pas ginette kolinka ne
compte plus les fois où elle a foulé le
sol du camp de birkenau en pologne
elle y revient souvent avec des classes
de lycéens français je sais pas en tout
cas moi je n'ai jamais vu cet endroit
ginette ne reconnaît pas ces lieux où
elle a vécu une horreur indicible alors
qu'il avait 19 ans tout ce que vous
lisez tout ce que vous voyez tout ce que
vous entendez faut pas dire cet exo
juristes n'ont rien au contraire même
tout est trop faible
ginette a été déportés de france en 1944
arrêté par la gestapo avec son père à
léo scheer kaski son petit frère gilbert
qui avait alors 12 ans et son neveu
georges 14 ans on n'a jamais su si
ginette ne sais plus mais on vient
raconter que le voyage entre drancy et
la pologne a duré 3 jours 3 jours
entassés dans un wagon de marchandises
sans fenêtre sans nourriture sans eau
jusqu'ici la ue donneront la rampe des
juifs aux portes du camp de birkenau
on arrivait là c'était la cab et de la
séduction c'est là que l'on nous disait
ou tumeurs ou tu vu mais on ne savait
pas c'est le leur mort de ma vie c'est
là que j'ai dit à mon père et à mon
petit frère de monter sur les camions on
les aurait obligées à le faire puisque
la était trop vieux d'autres jeunes mais
c'est moi qui aurais dit et c'est un jeu
mais il m'a coûté assez c'est quand même
très très triste
li penser mais je mentirais si je disais
que j'ai envie de pleurer
non c'est pas vrai parce que maintenant
moi je sais plus ce que c'est cool
aurélie
l'apprentissage de la cruauté et de
l'humiliation orchestrée par les nazis a
été immédiat et que j'étais là pour nous
mater au mco mode et ça faisait partie
de la tactique de mou de nous affamer de
vous absolue est de nous fait la vie
dure
ça devait être dans les tableaux qu'ils
avaient et rincon plus était dans la
solution finale gardé par des gens qui
n'avaient plus de sentiment qu'au centre
tous ensemble au milieu les travaux
forcés les coûts la faim le froid
ginette ferme les yeux et on traîne les
étudiants avec elle dans un enfer
toujours bien gravée dans sa mémoire
elle allume la lumière là blocs au va et
un aigu pas les petites gamme seller au
stand elle pas sans les colas et vas-y
que je te distribuer des coups et je me
dis quelquefois je suis pas normal j'ai
reçu un coup sur le crâne
il y avait sept morts qui étaient
toujours sur nos têtes et qui nous
empêchait de vivre sinon on a travaillé
très dur c'est vrai et on recevait des
coups c'est vrai mais peut-être que ça
serait pas terrain qui évolue au dessus
de ma tête c'est mort cette borne qui
était prête à nous traiter dessus on
croyait les chambres à gaz parce que on
savait comment que ça se passait quand
tu faisais leurs tripes un million cent
mille déportés ont été assassinés ici
dont un million de juifs
au fil de la visite du musée d'auschwitz
des objets qui leurs ont appartenu
artefacts banal du quotidien serbe de
témoins de leur passage pour les
étudiants de la région de normandie
ils ont maintenant un nom un visage une
histoire c'est des choses qu'on voit
quand même dans les films mais c'est
toujours pire finalement cessé c'est
horrible de voir tout ça et c'est en
fait on n'imagine pas quand on voit le
livre avec tous les noms c'est
incroyable il ya des ya probablement des
milliers de pages avec des centaines de
noms sur les pages et ça représente
vraiment énormément de personnes c'est
horrible moi j'arrive même pas imaginer
et au final je ne veux même pas imaginer
je pense quelque chose que j'ai des
hommes à mes bras de temps avant la
libération des camps
ginette kolinka a été transféré de
birkenau à bergen belsen dragoon et
terezin stadt une chance dit elle qui
lui a sans doute permis de revenir en
vie je suis tombé sur quelle claque
elle pesait 26 kg elle était couverte de
boue et avait le typhus les encore ici
ginette part de chance à son retour en
france
moi j'ai une famille qui m'a chouchouter
kim a bichonné et kim a léché même
tranquillement tout doucement avoir une
bonne santé alors que pour les autres
c'était pas le cas il fallait à lui
toute petite fermette trouver un travail
et travailler pendant des décennies elle
n'a plus reparlé des camps pas même avec
son mari albert un ancien prisonnier de
guerre ni avec son fils vous n'êtes pas
obligés de me croire les témoignages
dans les écoles ce besoin de raconter
c'est venu plus tard quand elle est
devenue veuve elle va signer mais ça
fait rien on va continuer à la taper et
puis après on va la remettre debout pour
qu'elle continue à travailler il faut
pas que la mémoire disparaissent avec
elle et je pense que l'on nous doit de
raconter ce qui s'est passé pour pas que
ça se reproduise parce que oui
malheureusement je pense que je pense
que c'est possible que l'erreur se
répète c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas
oublier qu'on se souvienne de ce que les
gens veuillent cuisse et j'ai essayé le
cyclo rebaissait look ou ceux qui
gardent ginette kolinka en vie et en
grande forme aujourd'hui trop long à
mourir
et puis cap les retrouver la quantité
nécessaire la volonté de raconter de
passer la mémoire pour que plus jamais
on laisse la haine triomphé hier il
s'est tellement les juifs plutôt à
l'avant s'il savait tout ce qu'ils
allaient nous faire on n'était même pas
encore arrêté qu'il savait échasses et
lan et c'est pour ça que si vous avez
tendance à dire moi j'aime pas cela moi
j'aime pas cela moi j'aime pas seul à
penser que c'est à prier dans swiss fort
saisie
si vous y arrivez parce que
malheureusement il ya encore battant des
gens qui haïssent parce qu'ils sont pas
comme suit pas ce qui se passe
[Musique]